hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to slow down premature greying
okay so if you're losing the hair color
here are some things that you can do
first you need to know is that the cells
that make the pigment called melanocytes
they make melanin which form the pigment
and not just in your hair but in your
eyes your skin and you actually have
something called Milano genic clock and
this is basically a clock involved in
the aging process and as you get older
you lose the color of your hair and you
go gray what we want to do is prevent
the premature graying effect okay and
keep the color there as long as possible
so there are several things involved one
is tyrosinase okay this is an enzyme
that has copper in it and you need this
enzyme to make melanin okay and you can
get this enzyme in mushrooms by the way
so mushrooms are one thing you can start
consuming alright also copper containing
foods I don't recommend copper
supplements I recommend foods high in
copper oysters seafood liver are all
foods that are high in copper okay or
just do the mushrooms alright that's one
thing number two your adrenals when your
adrenals are stressed what happens is
you start generating excessive amounts
of hydrogen peroxide now if you know
about hydrogen peroxide it can oxidize
something if you put it on your hair
it'll take the color right out of your
hair try this no don't try this just so
happens that the remedy is vitamin E
vitamin E will help decrease excessive
amounts of hydrogen peroxide in your
body because this is an oxidant this is
an antioxidant vitamin E does a lot of
things in your body it has properties of
anti sterility in other words it
increases fertility it helps combat hot
flashes it helps reduce the intensity of
spider veins
it helps premature wrinkles and improves
your skin the pituitary is the storage
for a lot of your vitamin E okay
so when you go into menopause and you
lose the function
the ovary because you're not going to
have babies anymore guess what happens
your vitamin E drops significantly women
that are pre menopausal or menopausal
have much lower vitamin E levels than
they did before that change of life so
this is one of the reasons why the
build-up of hydrogen peroxide because
they don't have enough vitamin E okay so
if you're menopausal make sure you eat
more leafy greens seeds nuts wheat germ
oil is really good or take a vitamin E
complex don't do a synthetic version get
the whole complex okay because it can
help you a lot of different levels and
one more reason why you might go gray is
you're deficient in either PABA biotin
or inositol these are B vitamins okay
but it's not because of your diet it's
because of the microbiome the gut flora
the bacteria in your gut that actually
help to produce these and help recycle
these so for example if you take an
antibiotic or have a situation where you
lose your friendly bacteria it can
greatly reduce these key vitamins that
are essential in keeping the color as
well so one area that you might want to
look at and prove is your gut take a
really good probiotic alright guys
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis about that